Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 28th, 2013. Uh,
I apologize for it being a this late
and I'm going to pause for all the truly
angry people out there.
Um,
let them get that out of this
system moves you through. You know,
one of the key things you got to figure
out in life is who you're really mad at.
You know, are you really
mad at me? You never met me.
I haven't done nothing to you.
Um,
I apologize. I had a crazy frigging
weekend. Now last I talked to use,
unless you're new to the podcast and if
you're new, welcome. Huh? Look at me.
I'd say I'm borderline
jovial at this point.
Welcome to the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
last I spoke with you,
I was on my way to Hawaii
and I was going to go to the pro bowl.
Then initially I was going to
stay there for a week, but uh,
I ended up getting some acting work,
which is great.
So I had to cut it short and tell the
lovely near that I couldn't take her to
Hawaii. I'll have to do it next time. And
basically I was going to go out there,
I was going to do my show through republic
and then I was going to go to the pro
bowl the next day, you know,
then go look at a volcano,
whatever the fuck I was going to
do when I was going to fly back.
But at least I was going to do
that. And um, I ended up, uh,
getting another acting gig on Monday.
And I know what you're thinking.
Jesus fell, Eh, you're acting
all over the place, you know,
and you know what? No,
I'm not. No, I'm not.
Okay.
I'm not,
it's just this business knows,
it knows when you, when you're
planning to do something fun. You know,
I don't have any fun plans next month.
No vacations,
not waterskiing. I'm not
taking that, that, uh,
that needle point class
that I've had my eye on.
I don't have any fun plans next month.
And you know what I have for acting worth?
I got shit.
I got nothing.
This fucking God damn business. It's
saw it felt it. Felt it in the universe.
Oh, look at Billy, right face.
Oh, freckle face himself.
He's going to go to the islands.
Go to a game. Ever. Good time, man.
I go fuck yourself as a couple
of acting gigs. You go out there,
you do just stand up Gig. All right?
You go to bed, you get on a plane,
you fucking come right back. Nothing
for you. That's what I did this weekend,
okay?
I worked Friday night. Saturday. I
got on a fucking plane by myself.
All right. And I'm sitting there
and you know when you fly to Hawaii,
I've never done this before.
They have like on the monitors
that play in the music,
they already got the music on where?
Well, well, well, well, well, well,
well who could do bup, bup,
bup, bup, [inaudible], right.
Whatever the fight, they kept
that shit. You're already,
you already feel like you're in Hawaii
and I'm sitting there like an asshole.
I'm looking around, everybody's got
their wife or their girlfriend, you know,
or whatever their fantasy football,
fucking hand job, boyfriend,
whatever the fuck they got,
whatever the hell it is.
When guys all go on a vacation
and they're not in their twenties,
whatever the fuck that's called the,
we're sick of a fucking wives vacation.
I don't know what it is. And I'm
sitting there like an asshole. Right?
So I fly out there,
crack of dawn,
fly out there and uh,
I can't even remember the fucking
weekend. Yeah. Nia didn't give me a ride.
So must have been really early. You kind
of have this deal. If it's too early,
I just jumped in a cab.
So I took a cab to the airport,
got on the fucking plane, flew
out there, landed and you know,
cause I wasn't bringing my girls just
like fuck it. I'll stay at whatever,
stay at the cheapest place out of the
three that were given to me. Right.
So when I show up to this fucking place,
it's like I show up. I'm the only guy,
like under the age of like 78 there.
It's just a bunch of fucking
old people and there's an,
I hop built into the place and
there's like a fucking homeless guy.
It just,
I felt like I was staying in like
the Port Authority section of Hawaii.
And what makes it worse is I got there
at 12 noon and my room wasn't ready until
three so now I'm sitting there like this
fucking asshole and I'm like adamant,
I'm not going to the,
I hop they have those on the mainland.
I want to do some island shit
and the fucking 12 hours,
then I'm going to be here.
And there was a diner on the corner
and I went there.
Okay.
And I, I'm standing, there's like
fucking 12 people online. I'm like,
you gotta be shitting me, right?
This is just a stupid touristy place.
There's fucking candy wrappers on the
ground before you even go in there is the
recess wrapper on one side.
There's the cup from the Reese's cup.
Like somebody just fucking just ripped
it open. Like just, it was such forced,
the Reese's cup went up in the air. He
fired both fucking parts of the package.
He pardons port and starboard and
then just gulp it down as he ran up,
not paying for it or whatever.
Looked like there was some,
so somebody got mugged who had some candy,
you know. So I'm sitting there going,
this is a fucking shit hole, but I
don't have a car. And I'm like fuck it,
I'm going to stay right. So I go
there and I ordered this thing. Yeah.
That evidently was a Hawaiian dish and
just turn out to be a burger patty with
some gravy and some eggs and a,
I'm sitting there eating it by myself.
Mind you,
I can't go to the pro bowl now cause I
have to fly right the fuck back at, uh,
I was sitting there and I'll send,
this guy taps me on, on my shoulder.
I look over and he goes, hey,
she'll be going, what? What, what?
What do you know that that
looks delicious? And I look
at the guy and I'm like,
I know this fucking guy who was this guy?
He looked like a mix between hulk
Hogan and triple h. So I kept thinking,
is this guy a fucking wrestler?
Okay.
And then I, I told him, I go, I don't
know what the name of the dishes,
but it just say hamburger patty with
eggs and gravy and they'll get it to,
and he laughed and he goes, hey, thanks.
And he walked away and I sat there
for five minutes and I was like, fuck,
that was Kevin Greene, former
Pittsburgh Steeler. Swear to God,
I'm 90% sure it was him.
So that was the one cool
thing that happened to me.
Somebody who I think was Kevin
Green asked me what I was eating.
I told them I didn't know what the
name of it was. He laughed and he left.
And then I ate that shit. And they go,
do you want dessert? It's like, no,
I don't want dessert,
but I still have two hours and 15 minutes
to kill before my fucker rumps ready.
So bring it on, lady. What
do you got? What do you got?
You got some hooky loud fucking
hookup. Luca. Luca fucking ice cream.
Cause I want it.
I want to do something Hawaiian cause
I'm leaving in fucking 12 hours. Right.
So they got this Hawaiian fried ice
cream. And immediately I'm thinking, well,
isn't that just what, you know, Mexicans
do that right? This is just the same shit.
So what, I never had fried
ice cream before, so go, Yo,
let me get to Friday scream,
fuck it.
And I'm sitting there and I'm sitting now,
there's old ladies looking
like this checklist please.
She looked like, you know,
like whenever they interview people who
are still alive that aren't like Alfred
Hitchcock movies, like that chick from
the birds or maybe the chick from psycho.
That's what she looked like. But like
courage. Now she's sitting there,
okay.
Yeah, she's a, you know, an
old red head. And I'm like,
is that what I'm going to look like?
Except for like the male version,
this is what I'm thinking
about in paradise, you know,
paradise sitting in
some shit fucking diner.
This is all stuff they don't show
you on the brochure by the way.
Sit into some shit fucking diner.
And uh,
so by the way, the food was
delicious. I got to tell you this,
it was delicious, but it was a dump. Um,
okay.
Sweating like 15 minutes go by.
I'm like, it's fucking ice cream.
Okay,
what are you doing? Just scoop it
out of the thing. And I'm like,
are they really frying this?
How do you fry it without melting it?
Is the dumbest podcast ever
say. Finally, bring it over.
It's this big goop of fucking shit and
it's just surrounded by this moat of whip
cream.
Okay.
You know,
and I ate the whole fucking thing out
of sheer be like trying to kill time.
It's probably like 3000 calories.
Plus I had a burger with gravy,
gravy on it with two eggs over easy.
All of it.
Delicious.
A wonderful thing to eat if
you're fucking 14 years old.
But if you're 44, it's not
a good scene. So anyways,
I finally get into the um, the
hotel. Oh, we have a package for you.
Look at the package is the package and
look at the package and it's the fucking
pro bowl tickets that I'm not going to.
And I hand them over to my buddy,
a fucking Rosebowl legend Jason Law head.
He takes him out.
They like glowing that shit and pulp
fiction. And I'm like, and I'm in my head,
I'm like, dude, you've got to put those
things away. I didn't say it. I was like,
Oh yeah, it's great man. I have a great
time. I heard they're great seats.
You fucking cook. True. Um, so whatever,
oh, I forgot this part. I
come walking out of the, uh,
the diner and that homeless guy I saw
sitting there who looked like Kenny
Rogers,
if he never got the plastic surgery
and like lived outside since the Nixon
administration, right? He's
sitting there and when I come out,
there's a security guard there,
you know, no gun, no authority.
He's just sent out their baby face.
He's like fucking 21 years old.
And I could see his body language
like God, Jesus Christ, right?
And all I hear is the homeless
guy lie. No, I'm not leaving
Chevy to jail cause I don't want to.
And you see the kid like, dude,
I really don't want to fight.
You think I want to do this job.
Somebody sent me out of here and I'm just,
and I just start fucking
laughing to myself because I,
for some reason I didn't think I was
good. You know, I'm going to Hawaii.
I feel like I'm going to paradise.
It's not going to be homeless people here.
It's fucking paradise. Right.
And, and it was the same shit,
the same shit or was an air in an area.
I felt like I was going to get mugged.
I found out later that there's a bunch
of hookers in that area. I was like,
we talked about this, a bunch of a
people with kids. They're like, no, no.
At night, at night they all come
out. And I was just like, you know,
how did they get out there?
You know,
how many dicks did they
suck to get out there?
And like how many fucking a,
I dunno, a spiritual change.
How long were you begging?
So we tried to tell me that cities put
their homeless guys on planes and fly
them out there. Like they say, said
they call it the rainbow project.
And I didn't believe that for a fucking
second. And I didn't give a shit.
If you send me documented proof,
there's no fucking way.
You get a crazy homeless guy and
all his funk on a fucking plane
get out. They can still
refuse your service. No Way.
He's coming on there with this fucking
horrific feet and elbows and all the,
you know, there's no way. There's no way.
And plus the guy's going to fucking
have a seizure by the time he gets there
from alcohol withdrawal,
you know those amps stells they sell
on the plane are going to help him.
But you know what I think it is.
I think it's just being around
the beach like a beach bum.
There's something about being
around the beach like, yeah,
I'll get to it tomorrow.
You know? Yeah, it did.
I did. I pay Red AG. Can't remember nick
scene or you're homeless. The it guy,
you know, give a fuck whether it's
nice sleep under a palm tree. You know,
I don't, I wasn't even there long
enough. So I did my show at this place,
the Republic Republic, and it was
the shit crowd was fucking awesome.
Sold out.
Thank you to everybody who came out.
I'm definitely coming back with
some of the best energy. I,
I've had it a show since I can remember
people were so psyched that somebody
from the mainland flu,
flu is pastey ass all the way out there.
I ran into one guy, he like flew
over from another island. Um,
and it was like, it was
locals, it wasn't Taurus.
And I found the couple of times
I've performed on islands,
people who live on islands a
fucking cool as hell. You know,
I did a Gig on Nantucket, uh, last
year, you know, and I met up, you know,
fishermen and Pete,
people who are there year round through
all the weather and all that shit.
It's just a, they're good people
man. So I had a great time there. Uh,
finished my show, you
know, whored myself out,
sold the DVD, smiling and waving. I
had two beers, went back to the hotel,
slept for four and a half,
five hours,
got on a fucking plane and flew right
back. Oh wait, wait. I bought a magnet
to prove like technically I can't
even say I was there cause I didn't do
anything.
I did walk down to the beach for half
a second and took a picture of myself,
whichever deadly is called a selfie.
I learned that on Chelsea.
Peretti is Twitter,
it's called the Selfie.
I took one of those with a mountain in
the background sorta for the bunch of
buildings and uh, but
you know, the upside was,
uh, sold out. The crowd was awesome.
I'm definitely gonna come back and,
uh,
I think that there is going to
be another pro bowl because, uh,
I guess the game was, was
you know, a bunch of scoring.
They were sort of hitting and I think
the NFL was just sort of threatening the
players. Like, Hey, quit
fucking dog in the entire game.
Cause it's an embarrassment to the league,
you know,
how about a mild concussion?
Can you give that up for the league
just so we can keep this thing going?
You know, so it isn't a total fucking
embarrassment what or whatever.
I had a great time when
I was out there. The, uh,
I don't know what the fuck I landed at 12.
I left the next morning at five.
What is that, 17 hours,
you know? [inaudible] um,
yeah,
yeah.
Then I flew back.
I did a fucking acting gig where they
put some glued some shit to my face.
Did that this morning,
and then I flute fucking back here
and I'll do my podcast and uh,
Neil was giving me shit. You kind
of do the podcast. Oh, you know,
they do that. Like she, I
don't know, women are great.
They just want to hang out if he would,
if you're just doing it with them.
Like she actually does actually reality
show that she's watching right now that
I can watch because it's a
bunch of, I dunno, you know,
it's a bunch of morons, but they're morons
that I can relate to. Um, all right.
What are we doing here? I'm going to
make sure I do the fucking advertising.
I kind of screwed this up last
week. Um, all right everybody,
a little bit of advertising here on the
Monday morning podcast, uh, legal zoom,
everybody, uh, you know, what you
need to accomplish at the start
of the new year.
You need to think about legal
protection for your family and business.
But where do you turn for
affordable legal solutions?
You can trust legal zoom.com.
These guys are great.
These guys basically take care of all
that pain in the butt stuff that you know
you should be doing but you put off,
you know,
you can get it all done@legalzoom.com
and it won't cost you a fortune.
They have an a rating from
the better business bureau.
Legal Zoom has been helping families
and businesses get personalized legal
protection for the past 12 years.
Whether you need to incorporate
your business form an LLC
or protect your family
with the will or a living trust.
All a legal zoom documents are state
specific and they're step by step process
makes it simple. Um, yet for some reason
I can't read the copy cause I'm a moron.
And with legal zoom,
you can,
you can even access an extensive network
of legal plan attorneys for guidance.
So basically you can
take care of all of that.
They got a step by step process if I
can say it, to walk you through it.
And a,
if you actually have any problems,
they have attorneys that
will give you guidance. Uh,
legal zoom is not a law firm.
You can get self help service at your
specific direction or you can speak to a
legal plan attorney to get your questions
answered and get ongoing advice, uh,
before another year passes a passage.
You by cross a couple of things
off your New Year's checklist
today@legalzoom.com and save a
pile of money while doing it.
Enter
bur
in
the
referral
box@checkoutforevenmoresavingsatlegalzoom.com.
A highly recommend that
everybody, um, do not wait.
That's the kind of thing that you put
off and then something horrific happens
and you didn't do it and people are left
with their pockets turned inside out.
Please don't do that. I don't
wish that on anybody, you know,
and I know it's a pain in the butt and
legal zoom.com makes it easy, right?
They ago this, a little
advertising, a little advice.
Uh, real quick. Uh, what do we got now?
A stamps.com, the old favorites here.
Uh, if you haven't heard yet,
postage rates have changed again.
You know what that means?
The post office,
will he be even more crowded than usual?
That's why you need stamps.com,
stamps.com everybody, if you never want
to go to the post office again yet,
be able to do everything that you want
to do at the post office right from your
own home. Um, you can do anything there.
You can print a legal postage,
you can do right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage for
any letter or package using your own
computer,
a printer and stamps.com always upstate
the postage rates for you automatically
so you don't have to think about it.
You don't have to think back.
Go back down to the post office and
get the 2 cent stamp and stick it on or
forget be out of the loop and have
that important bill come back to you.
They handle all of it.
Stamped Cup stamps.
Dot coms always updates the postage rates.
You'll never have to go
to the post office again.
I use stamps.com for the
last little over a year.
I've been sending my DVDs to
all my, uh, all my, uh, my, my,
whatever the hell I'm trying to say. All
My standup events. Good God Almighty.
So I don't, I'm sorry. I flew in
three planes in the last two days. Uh,
right now use my last name bur
bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer offer
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com. Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Burp Turr.
That's stamps.com and
enter burr. Okie dokie. Uh,
back to the podcast here. Um,
all right, so what's coming up?
Do you know what's coming up this
week, but by fucking show football,
dude,
who do you like?
This is what I'm doing for the Super Bowl.
All right?
I have to work the day of the
Superbowl. Believe it or not. Alright.
Old twinkle toes. Just
finishing up an acting gay.
Karen. Speaking of acting gigs,
um, I have a movie coming out or
there's a movie coming out that I'm in.
It's not my movie,
it's a movie I'm happy to be in.
It's called standup guys comes
out February 1st. All right.
Stars,
Al Pachino,
Christopher Walken and Alan Arkin and
old Billy red faces walking by in the
background for a couple of scenes.
Do not blink. You will miss me.
But do you remember back in April of
last year when the podcast was late and
everybody was given me a ton
of shit about it and I said,
you wait Nate fucking months.
I'm gonna have the greatest excuse ever.
I was late that day because I was in a
scene with a Al Pachino and Christopher
Walken a right? So go fuck
yourself. That's why it was like,
how do you like that? How do you like
them apples? Huh? I'm a Boston guy.
Can I say that?
I grew up in the suburbs.
You can only say that
if you're from Southie
anyways. Um, I'll be working
on the day of the Superbowl,
but I don't give a shit because,
uh,
in my limited wisdom, I think I've, I've,
I've figured out how to watch
the super bowl. All right.
Not only do you watch it by yourself,
okay, so most important game of the year,
it's for the championship. He's fucking
guys, they're playing a game. Wait,
they're going to die. Oh, by the rugby.
People are paying attention to the
level of concussions are right.
They are leading with your shoulders and
no pads. Not saying he not tough. Okay.
Okay.
I think this finally proves that American
football is the most psycho fucking
sport there is that psycho sport.
But you know what I mean?
I wouldn't even say it's tougher
than rugby ball sports. A tough,
but like the whole thing that English
people, and they always say that, oh,
they got helmets on their fucking pussies.
All the helmet does is make you think
that you're protected and you use it as a
weapon,
but your fucking brains in there in the
fucking water and it's slam it all over
your head. And then when you're 40,
you shoot yourself in the chest,
you know,
so,
so the scientists can fucking look at
your brain and figure what's going on in
there. The rugby people do
that 40 I don't think you do.
I think he's still running around out on
the pitch with the fucking masking tape
around your ears. As far
as my research goes, sorry.
Every once in a while I get to
wake those cuts up. Um, so anyways,
this is how I'm going to watch the super
bowl. You got to watch it by yourself.
You got to get away from the
fucking, the, the, the, the I,
all the brides that come over,
including the, the fucking guy broads,
you know the ones who don't watch football
and they just show up for the dip and
they're there.
They're there with the fucking
chicks they're trying to get laid in.
Your fucking house is
basically what they're doing.
They talked during the game and they shut
up during the commercial and then when
the game comes back on the like, I didn't
like that one. I thought that was good.
How much do you make that cost?
Right.
And meanwhile you can't
even watch the fucking game.
And then every fucking year they got
to have some Waylon whore or some agent
fucking rockstar with hair plugs come
out there for one last fucking swing at
glory.
So this is what you do.
People invite you to the, Hey, wait, what
are you doing for a soup bowl? Eh, ah,
you know what? I'm, I'm mum going,
Nah, I got this thing I got to do.
Ah, yeah, I got to go out in the
woods, come up with something.
Or just just, you know what? Why are you
going to lie? I'm watching it by myself.
Why are you going to do that? Because
I want to watch the game. That's why.
All right, so now you've eliminated
all the clients that are that,
that are going to be in your living room.
Now that's stage one of the cont removal.
Stage two is to get rid of the country
you don't want to see that are on the
television.
And this is the most important part.
You record the fucking game. I know a lot
of people already do this ship of this.
People who don't, okay, so just bear
with me. He record the fucking game.
You shut up, you fucking cell
phone. You don't answer your phone.
You don't go on your computer,
all right?
And you just as is. The whole rest of
the world is watching somebody lip syncs,
some prerecorded.
Hey
Brad,
whatever the fuck they do,
write the fucking Jessica.
Go right over the fucking top.
You know what he did downstairs?
Spackle on a wall. Wait for
that red. That pink spackle,
the turn white so you can
sand that fucker down. Right?
But a little God damn pain on it.
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows from last year
when you punched the wall,
cause that fucking douche wouldn't shut
up during the game and he was double
dipping. You fucking put your
hand through. I'll fix that thing.
Patch that hole in the wall is everybody
is watching Huey Lewis and the news
went
Bam,
Bam.
Try to fucking kick off the game. Whoever
the fuck they got this year, right?
Okay.
They got Beyonce is going to sing whatever
the hell she's going to do with the
whole halftime.
She shouldn't be there unless she's
watching the why is she out there?
What you're going to get y'all out there?
A little glitter hot pants. You know,
I don't want to see that shit. So what
you do is you just let the game go.
Let it go for a good, I don't
know, 90 minutes, two hours.
Then you sit down like you
control the universe. Like you,
Jesus walking on the water,
except you sitting in your fucking chair
and you turn that fucker on and you hit
fast forward one, two, three,
four and you watch all the talking
heads and then you'd get your fucking,
you watch watching fast
Mohsen Adam and the ants,
whoever the fuck they have opened up.
Maybe Metallica sing in
a fucking Tom Petty Song.
Maybe Tom Petty's there with
them and that fucking, uh, uh,
would it hell's his name there?
Lou Reed.
Maybe he's out there singing and who the
fuck knows? That seems to be the thing.
You have the old people first,
then he gets some young hottie during
halftime sitting there with her tits
hanging out. Isn't that what
you're dealt? That's America. Um,
you fast forward to all that fucking
shit and the beginning and he just get
right to the kickoff.
You just watched the game at your leisure,
at your fucking leisure.
And then you know what happens after the
first half and they start wheeling that
big dumb fucking stage out there.
And every douche bag we ever had a
fucking dream of dancing is fucking,
you just taken up a whole football field
of fucking singers and dancers the most
and football fucking thing you
could possibly have. You know,
and everybody who talked to her in the
first half, they're all shutting up.
They're sitting there
on their fucking knees,
two feet from your fucking
breathing on your flat screen.
You now like it's the beginning
of the Mickey Mouse Club,
and they get their fucking ears on.
You fast forward through all of that shit
and he'd just go right in and then you
know what happens is you never
lose the flow of the game
now
before you're not.
Why don't you invite a couple people
over who want to do it that way?
People who want to shut the fuck
up real fence. And I suggest this,
if you want to sound intelligent to the
people that you're going to watch the
game with,
I highly recommend buying the sports
illustrated this week that has both of the
Har Brother harbor brothers. However, the
fuck you say their names on the cover,
both phenomenal coaches. Obviously they're
there in the Superbowl and Goddamn it,
they both of them,
if their teams didn't fuck up,
I know it's a big if 49,
it's didn't drop three fucking punch
or whatever the hell it did last year.
And uh,
you know,
at the Ravens did what they miss a
fucking extra point or something. I came,
it was like a chip shot, um, that,
that would have been back to back
years with them. Who knows them.
They both would've gone and then they
would've partied too much and then they
would have sucked this year.
That's what happens. But whatever.
MMM.
Anyways,
so they got this great article where they
break down the game at a level that I
wish I could,
I knew more of.
MMM.
They got
this thing and they
remember, remember one, uh,
what the fuck his name was going to say?
Hammer Lik been watching
too much fucking hockey.
What's the name of the a cam. Cameron.
The fuck's the name of the quarterback.
Kaepernick. What's his name?
Chris Kaepernick. Chip Kaepernick.
Uh, creepy Kaepernick. Whatever the fuck
his name is. The guy's the shit you don't,
when he was running wild like fucking
hulk Hogan against the Green Bay packers.
Basically he was, uh, they were,
they were breaking down that play,
trying to see if they will
be able to run it. And they,
it's called the zone read
and they run it out of the,
the pistol alignment.
How cool is that?
Which is basically the shotgun formation,
but you're closer to the center.
So they call it the pistol alignment.
You've got to tail back right
behind you and this is what happens.
You hiked the ball,
quarterback turns around,
he puts the ball right in the
fucking bread basket of the tailback.
And right there.
He does his zone read,
which basically means he looks at that
defensive end of the linebacker who's
supposed to seal off the edge and
he basically does a quick read.
If the fucking guy holds his ground,
he just hands,
he continues handing the ball
off to the fucking tail back.
But if the fucking guy on the Ed
bites on it and starts to pension,
you pull it back and you fucking
run around, run around the side.
There you go.
Let's call the zone read from the pistol
alignment and the point where you're
holding the ball, almost giving
it to tailback but not really.
But maybe you had Ghana,
that's called the mesh point.
I wish I knew this shit. I really did.
But they have like 10 pages on this shit.
Talking about the ravens
defense, their running game, eh,
was absolutely fascinating.
So much better than watching a ESPN and
watching herm Edwards screaming or that
guy with the hair and the cold
pizza yelling, you know, you know,
he always sucked in gym class.
He reeks of it, reeks of it.
He looks like he's good at like
rich white guys sports like uh,
I'd say Polo but he's so fucking short.
He'd probably fall off the
horse trying to hit that goal.
I think maybe my badminton.
There you go. Bad Man.
Maybe he's good at Badman but um,
this is like everything you want to know
without the screaming and yelling and
I'm really being a nerd right now
because I'm basically saying the book is
better than the movie but uh,
I highly recommend reading that shit and
then watching the game by yourself and
seeing if he can pick
out the pistol alignment.
Yeah,
the zone read and the pistol
alignment, you know, I dunno.
That type of Shit excites me.
Don't you want to know what the
cover too is for once in your life?
Don't you wish you could watch football?
These fucking assholes playing fantasy
football and fucking with their faces two
inches from the God damn screen.
Memorize and stats.
Wouldn't you want to be up in the stands?
Being able to see what each is doing
and how teams are adjusting.
Like last week it was like,
or two weeks ago when the
49 is where all of this,
they were down 14 nothing or something
crazy and all of a sudden it just stopped
and they came back and every
goal, Kaepernick, Kaepernick,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
I'm reading this fucking
article and the uh,
one of the offensive coordinators
or the 49 is like, Nah,
you know, after, you know,
bought a quarter,
quarter and a half,
we kind of saw what they were doing and
then we adjusted to it. Then you're like,
oh,
that's what happened.
Okay.
I just stopped the momentum changed
magic. Like I watch it. It's such a,
I'm a ball watcher. I
hate it. I hate that I am,
I wish I could sit up in the stands. It'd
be like, oh, it's a fucking, you know,
I don't know any other defense other than
cover too. I love when, what's his face?
I actually hate it when Gruten starts
talking about the defenses and stuff.
They got eight girls and the books and
they start throwing up this terminology.
It's like, why don't you
fucking tell me what it means?
You know,
I dunno. Bill, why don't you utilize
the Internet and fucking look it up?
I'm sure there's a youtube video bought
it. Okay, you got me. So anyways,
that's how I'm watching the, uh, that's
how I'm watching the Superbowl thoughts.
Anyone, anybody, is this even remotely
fucking interesting? I don't, I don't,
you know, whatever you, you know my
policy, I always tape in the morning.
I never take on days when
I flew on a fucking plane,
but I had no choice because I
had to fly today. All right. Um,
all right, last piece of advertising
for this week. He voice everybody. Uh,
he voices what busy professionals
use to save time and to work smarter.
Eve always converts all your voicemails
to texts and sends it directly to your
cell phone.
No more interrupting your day to check
your voicemail or waiting till after a
meeting to find out what's
going on. Uh, with he voice.
Your calls will always be rooted
to you and no matter where you are,
evil voice also comes with
your own conference line
for up to 94 participants on
a single call.
You could have literally ended the
NHL lockout with 94 participants.
That's gotta be every owner plus, uh,
the three guys on their top lines, right?
Um,
it all starts for less than $10 per month,
but right now they have a special offer
for our prep. For my podcast listeners,
you can get, he voiced free for
six months with no obligation.
For your free six month trial,
please go to www dot [inaudible] dot
com and enter the Promo Code Bill.
All right.
Yeah.
Perfect. If you're trying to start up
a business, it's only 10 bucks a month,
he should pay that anyways and then
given it to you for six months.
You have no excuse. Go there
now, please. All right.
Back to the podcast here. Uh, what
else did I want to talk about? Oh,
I saw a good documentary this week.
This is more me reminiscing about my week.
Okay.
Sort of a verbal diary, audio diary. Um,
I saw this a new
documentary on Ginger Baker,
which is funny.
I used to listen to when I was growing up,
Ginger Baker and I thought it was just
a nickname. This is before ginger,
that term jump the ocean
and came over here, uh,
from Ireland, Scotland and
England. He was a red headed dude,
Ginger Baker or whatever. So the
name of this podcast, a podcast,
the made this documentary is beware of
Mr. Baker and I don't care if you play
drums or not, there's no way
you're not going to enjoy this.
This guy's one of the most interesting
human beings have ever seen in my life.
You guys think I'm a crabby old
fucking man. You got to see this guy.
Yeah.
And He trashes John Bonham.
Okay.
He trashes them and I'm going to say
what he says here in about five seconds.
So fast forward if you don't
want me to ruin it. But uh,
for those of you who don't play drums,
nobody trashes John Boehner
unless you just some troll.
I'm trying to Piss people off
on the Internet. It's like he's,
he's the fucking king as far
as rock drummers go to guys,
the king, it's, you know,
there, there is definitely the WHO's
better Barnum apart and they argue,
but nobody ever says that Bonham
sucks if you're just being a Douche.
But Ginger Baker actually,
they asked him what he thought about John
Bonham and I guess people trashed you
on the Internet because
there's so many constant.
But anytime you ever asked a drummer,
a rock drummer about John [inaudible],
they all just in hush
tones speak of the power,
his swing,
his feel,
his subtlety is originality
is the triplets,
the single bass drum,
the whole fucking thing.
Ed Ginger Baker said John Bonam
couldn't swing a sack of shit.
It was one of the fucking, I,
my jaw was almost on the ground.
I couldn't fucking believe it.
And I just burst out laughing.
I've never
do you hear somebody who's considered
a god just dismissed like that.
And then even like Clapton,
he didn't shit on Barna but like
clapped and they were like, you know,
how do you compare bottom to Ginger
Baker? And he was just like, ah Nah, Nah.
He's like, you know, it's not even
a, basically it's not even a contest.
Ginger Baker was a fully formed musician,
a composer and [inaudible]
and all this type of stuff.
Okay.
I Dunno, it just for me, I don't like,
I mean I've actually looked at
photos online and considered blue,
having them blown up and hanging them in
my house of John Bonham and that's like
what I think of them and just
to hear somebody just, you know,
basically he's like my Lance Armstrong,
like you know something like
from my Lance Armstrong moment,
you know when those people got all
disappointed, like what do I tell my kids?
My Lance Armstrong moment would be if I
found out that in the studio he actually
played a double pedal or
a double bass drum nine.
All lot of you guys are going to show
that picture of him with the double bass
drum set up. I know the story that
that was all when he first got the kit,
when,
what's his face hooked him up with it.
This is so fucking inside at this point.
You'd have to be a drama to even like
any of this carbon apathy car mine apathy
or a PC of have like 58 different
pronunciations of their last name.
He had a deal with Ludwig and I think
bottom initially was playing Slingerlands
and Karma and got him in with Ludwig and
he got the same set up that car might
had.
So he had the double bass and he brought
it to like one rehearsal and the other
guys in the band just kept
taking the other bass drum out.
Just go and you don't need it.
It's cluttering up everything. Um,
I really can't imagine him
playing a double bass drum
set. He would have fucking
drowned out the whole God damn bed.
Um,
but whatever anybody thinks
he doesn't have a fast foot,
just watch him at Royal Albert Hall
in 1970 then he can go fuck yourself.
But evidently ginger Baker says
he couldn't swing a sack of shit,
which just killed me.
Um,
if you just want to see a fucking
angry redhead playing drums,
because I haven't made any drum videos,
right,
Jeff,
this is the guy. This is the
real deal. Uh, it's called, uh,
beware of Mr. Baker,
um,
underrated listening to ginger
Baker for a fucking hour and a half.
It was awesome.
And then I actually watched some of the,
the comeback shows that they had,
the one at Royal Albert Hall and he was
fucking unbelievable drums just sounded
amazing and incredible player. Uh, but
that's just the tip of the iceberg.
It's just how he lives,
his life going broke and just
moving on from relationships. Um,
really an amazing documentary.
So anyways, with that,
let's get to some of your questions here.
I feel like I've been running my mouth
here for fucking almost 40 minutes here.
Um, Bill heard you love drinking.
Hey Man, heard you love to drink.
And I agreed.
Drinkings great.
But I haven't been handling
my liquor too well of late.
I've been getting blackout drunk every
night for a while now except for a week.
What did we, you blacked out drunk
when you wrote this? I've been getting,
I've been getting blackout drunk every
night for a while now, except for a week,
maybe a month here and there. Okay.
There we go. That was on me. Sorry. What?
I want to remember things that have
actually happened and not just night
terrorists. Any tips on
drinking? Semi responsible.
Um,
I really would like to continue to use
it as a social lubricant and overall good
time liquid. Thanks for the free
rank, right? Uh, you're welcome. Um,
okay.
I've been getting blackout drunk
every night for a while now. Ah, dude,
you sound like a, I'm, I love to
drink, but I don't get blackout drunk.
I get just to the point
where I say something I wish
I didn't say and I don't do
it every night.
I'm getting blackout drunk every night.
It depends on your age. I mean, if you're
like, I don't know, seven. Yeah, 18,
18 and you just discovered alcohol
and you, you're fucking, you know,
drinking the way you fuck
90 miles an hour. Um,
that's the only semi scary.
Even that scary, but a, yeah.
Do blackout drunk is some serious shit.
Um, I dunno, I would talk to somebody a,
I dunno what I would do if I was getting
blackout drunk every fucking night.
I think I would quit for a while.
Well,
I get to a point where I just embarrass
myself too much and then I just need to
like back off. Um, I've been
really big on bare lately.
I go back and forth between Scotch and
beer and I got into beer and I got into
the whole fancy fucking beers
now back to beer that I like.
My Dad drank and my friends'
dads drank when I was a kid.
So it was basically beer that we stole.
So every once in a while go back to beers
and I drank in high school and I drink
them. And it's this weird sort of like,
you know, I don't want to taste it.
I just think about, I always pictured,
you know, just drinking in the woods.
The cops did the cops coming.
Um, so yeah, that would be,
that would be my, uh, look,
if you're not an alcoholic,
I would just monitor your drinking,
but if you're getting blackout drunk
every night, you might have a problem.
So I wouldn't want to tell you how to
drink semi responsibly because if you're
an alcoholic, you're not going to. Um,
so I would explore a little more your
level of addiction and when you figure
that out,
I would then act accordingly.
And if you figure out
that you're an alcoholic,
I would try and quit drinking as soon as
possible because it will ruin your life.
Uh,
believe me,
I said something fucking horrible
this weekend after I did my shows,
it was only after like two beers.
Okay.
I'm going to try to figure out how to
tell this story without outing anybody in
it. I'm sitting there, I haven't
drank since two girls come up. Ah,
you a funny, but blah blah. Hey, thanks
a lot. How long you staying out here? Uh,
I got to leave in five hours. What
are you a fucking moron? Yes I am.
That type of shit.
And so they pointed this girl,
she's like the girl next door
going, hey, you know what she does?
What do you think she does?
And I was listening. You say,
I can get a read and I just
couldn't get a read on this girl.
I don't know what she did.
She looked like she would
just work in customer service,
but there was something
different about her,
but it was because she looked like
that I couldn't, uh, she just like,
she just get a regular job, you
know, get married, become a mom,
one of those people that just happy so
they don't need to go out and try to
achieve some stupid fucking goals so
they can then get trashed on Twitter.
So anyways,
they go,
she actually flies those
giant cargo planes with like
the three tanks in the bag
that they drop out with the
fucking parachutes. And I'm
like, are you shitting me?
Like that's all right. I'm blown away.
And then she points at her friend
and goes, hey, this is my friend. Uh,
she used to be a cheerleader for this
professional football team, right?
They tell me that and now I'm thinking
bullshit. I'm like, all right,
you're a fucking pilot. Not saying
the other girl wasn't good looking,
but I'm kind of drunk at
this point because I haven't
eaten. Only had two beers.
That was the thing, only had two
fucking peers, but even a two beers,
the level of asshole. I am
at stone sober, two beers in,
I say to law head, I go, I just, you
know, kind of whisper to him. I go,
there's no way. She was a
cowboys cheerleader. She,
her rack isn't big enough and
then she just goes clear as day.
Did you just say my rack isn't big enough.
It felt like a fucking ass hole.
Then I'm thinking,
I thought I whispered that evidently
I yelled at over the fucking music.
Um, and then I had to try
and talk my way out of that.
I wasn't saying she wasn't good looking,
but you know, you watch him on TV,
they make it look like they
all got fucking, you know,
fucking very least 34 c all
the way up to d cup titties.
The make look perfect. Most of them are
probably fake. It's like the fake teeth.
I told her, I said, look, every out
there has fake titties and Dallas,
this is be flailing trying to get out
of it or trying to, like, I felt bad.
I should just apologize. It wasn't drunk
really. You can't apologize for that.
I said it, she heard it. I'm an
asshole. But when I did say I go,
it's like the fake titty
capitol of the world.
She did give me a high five
and I thought it was fine.
But later on when I walked out, I
walked by, I think it was her husband,
she had a wedding ring on and I walked
by this guy and I thought he was waving
to many.
He holds up a cell phone and I see that
there's a picture of a Dallas cowboy
cheerleader on, on it. So
I think it was his wife,
which means she went over and told him,
and I want to thank that guy.
She told you and you didn't smash a
bottle over my head. I really want to,
I appreciate it. My fault. Uh,
next time I come out there,
I'll buy you some
fucking,
I dunno what,
whatever the Poo Poo platter or whatever
the fuck they have about their brutal.
So that's why I tried to drink at home.
You know, what am I gonna do?
Say something rude to my dog.
Oh Geez.
I'm really too old to have continued
to have new stories like this. Anyways.
All right, Bill, what's my move?
I'm a sophomore in college and not very
experienced with relationships. Um,
I met this girl about three weeks ago
in class and she seems pretty cool.
We've been hanging out progressively more
often during the last couple of weeks.
I feel like I've been getting signs
from her, but I'm pretty confused now.
She comes to my room and we hang out
on the bed lying close to each other.
Oh God, Dude. She's waiting
for you to make a move.
That's what your next move is.
Make a move.
We hang out on my bed line close to each
other and do homework or watch a movie
or whatever. She also texts me every
day. So yesterday we kissed for the first
hi gay.
Right?
Well they bring in the substitute guy
and all those nerves that keeping scores,
I fucking erasing shit.
You know?
Now batting how virgin out
of the boy in Iowa. Um,
anyway, so, so yesterday we kissed
for the first time before she left,
about 20 minutes after I get a text
from her with about six paragraphs
explaining how she kind
of has a boyfriend,
but he treats her like shit.
So it's pretty much over.
Ah, Jesus. You know what?
There's always a price to pay.
No matter what you do. It's like that
guy who doesn't want to drink anymore.
I want you to taper it down.
This is a price he's going to pay
and the price he's going to pay is,
he's going to be sitting there doing
the right thing, not drinking, wishing
okay.
That he could just sit there
and fucking pound 20 beers,
you know?
But he wants to take control
of his fucking life and
the price he has to pay is,
he can't ever do that again.
And then there's the other side.
You drank the 20 fucking beers and
then you know the price you pay.
Look at the price I paid after having
to fucking lightweight, you know,
say you go, you finally
make the move, you kiss her.
There's always a fucking price.
So you gotta ask yourself sauna,
you willing to pay this
price if you continue,
I'm not going to read the rest of
this cause I could tell you right now,
there is possibly a fucking beat down
slash double murder slash maybe double
murder suicide at the end
of this Pussy Rainbow.
MMM.
Anyways,
I'll read the rest and he goes,
and also she explains how she's
not ready for a relationship,
but we can still cuddle. I Dunno
about this. Yeah. Fuck this chick.
Okay.
He goes, I'm trying to get my
dick wet, but she also seems cool.
You're trying to get your dick wet.
This dude's not a virgin.
You speak in that you're speaking the
language. You want to get you a dick way?
Yeah, you, we have fucking, this
is a pistol fucking formation.
Okay.
All right. You kissed her. That's the mesh
point. You got to do a zone read here.
What's going on? What's going on right
here? Oh Two oh two right, right, right.
Come on to, you know what the fuck
you got to do right now? You don't,
you seem like a guy who got laid,
hasn't got laid for a while. So now,
or maybe you really liked this girl.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
All right.
Let me just read the rest of this fucking
thing. It's like two more sentences.
He says, I just don't want to be in the
same position for the next two months.
Should I give a shit about this girl?
And like getting bullshitty. Yeah,
you getting bullshitted.
She wants to get out of the relationship,
but she doesn't want to be lonely.
All right.
This is what you should say to say
look. All right. I think, uh, you know,
I don't do, I don't kiss girls who, yeah,
boyfriends. I don't do that
stuff and uh, I don't know.
Hang out with them laying on beds.
I would love to lay in a bed and kiss
you if you did not have a boyfriend.
So I think it would be best if a,
when that situation clears up,
you know?
Okay.
Then come by, you know,
but you know, wait awhile.
Give the guy an opportunity to see you
know, if he's going to kill you or not.
So I don't get caught in the crossfire
attic, you know, two, three months.
He doesn't kill you.
I know it's safe and I will
gladly bang you and my,
uh, my fucking bed, my single,
that's how I'd handle it. That's how I
should have handled that at your age.
But there weren't podcasts,
so I just had to listen to my deck.
Ah, fuck there. It was. There it was. It
took me 50 fucking minutes to be funny,
but there was all right, fiances, x.
Hey bill, I really appreciate the show.
Keeps me sane in the cubicle farm.
Well,
God bless you for fucking fighting the
good fight out there now to the meat of
the email.
This guy,
he thanks me in like a sentence
and a half and he gets right to it.
This is how you do it. People, this
is textbook. Uh, he goes, my fiance,
who I loved dearly,
has an ex boyfriend.
She maintains a friendship with
fucking drop this bitch right now.
Okay.
Sorry.
Kneejerk reaction.
Continuing listening without prejudice.
I am of the mindset that men and women
cannot maintain that kind of relationship.
Thank you.
Okay.
Preach on.
Especially if there was some kind
of dating involved in the past.
Uh,
I am not comfortable with this guy
and I am struggling with this. She
was struggling with this shit. I'm,
should I straight out
tell the con I don't like him being
around or do I take the more painful
approach and pretend everything's cool.
Okay.
One other quick question.
I have to make a run to New Mexico,
Mexico soon and wanted to snag the name
of that Italian place you were talking
about on the podcast
or so. Back ass. Fuck.
You know what?
It's right next to a Hilton Garden Inn.
Okay.
And it begins with a B like Bueno. Blaina,
something like that. Come on. Somebody
in New Mexico helped this guy out.
MMM.
And send it to me and I'll
read it next week off.
I'll figure it out by next
week. All right. That's a
promise. But anyways, yeah,
dude, you got it. You got, you got
to, this is, this is not cool at all.
It's not cool at all.
All right.
That's not cool at all,
guys.
Do not continue being friends with women.
I think women maybe can do it,
but guys can't do it.
He's trying to east trying to fucking,
just going to try to bang her,
do this. Fuck, this is your fiance.
You can't fucking have that.
You can't have that,
you know,
and uh,
this is what you gotta do you gotta tell
her that and when she gets mad and she
gets upset, well, I do know trustee
Blahblahblahblah blue, blue, blue.
You have to sit there and
totally maintain your cool.
Do not take the bait. If she starts
calling you names, if she's a name,
call and all that,
do not get upset.
Just say that like that
Shit I did in my act.
We will discuss this later when you calm
down. I don't want to argue about this.
Um, I don't think it's fair. The
position you're putting me in and um,
I would never do that to you.
I would never hang out with
an ex girlfriend of mine.
All right.
I don't think that that's cool.
So I would appreciate it if
you would not do that anymore.
Okay.
And if she continues to do it,
then um,
I would marry somebody else personally,
you know,
I'm not cool with that and my
relationship, I've had to deal with that.
You know, I have had to deal with that
a couple of times. Well, you know,
it was just kind of as a Frito, we took
an acting class and blah, blah, blah. No,
no.
I literally had to explain to you think
he's yes. Yes he is. He is tried to.
He has tried to. Yes, exactly.
You know,
or maybe he's,
he's hoping that you have hot friends
that he can try and fuck by. You know,
being the guy who hangs out
with the chicks. You know,
maybe he's trying to do that,
but he's trying to fuck something.
And if you're the only thing around,
he's going to try and fuck you. So no,
it's not cool.
MMM.
Anyways. All right, next one.
This is all fucking guys talking
about the ladies this week. Um,
stay with girl or not. All right. Hi,
Bill loved the podcast. Thank you.
In a tough situation.
So I would like to know your thoughts.
I've been with a girl for five
months in a few weeks into it.
She mentioned she had been in a
relationship for five years and he's still
friends with the guy. What
the fuck is this? The same
one? I already answered this.
Yeah.
Who I've met and who in a bad dude.
She used to talk to him a
lot so she seemed not over
him and mentioned that they
were basically fuck
buddies since breaking up,
which I don't mind happening but do mine.
Her thinking it's no biggie to tell me.
All right, let me, let me
try and do the math on that.
She mentioned they were basically
fuck buddies since breaking up,
which I don't mind happening, but do mind
her thinking it's no biggie to tell me.
So you don't mind if she's fucking this
guy on the side. Just don't bring it up.
Wasn't there an R and B song about that?
Okay.
Thinking about, girl, I don't want to know
something.
I can't fucking remember.
Anyways. It seemed like it was a
recent breakup, but when I asked her,
she said in a roundabout way, it was
about two years ago, about two months in,
she admitted that she had last slept
with them the week after she met me,
which was actually the night of the
day we met up for the first time.
So after our first date,
this sounds dumb,
but otherwise things are good and she's
okay.
Tone talking about him down
sense and is a good girl.
Different to a lot of
okay.
Ones in my past,
which is why I stayed with her after that.
This girl is fucking your brains out.
That's what's going on.
She likes sex and I guarantee you she
fucked this guy at least one more time
after your first date.
Okay.
That does. That's my instinct.
I'm not saying that's true.
That's just my instinct.
Anyways,
it says I'm 25 and haven't
had a girlfriend before out
of not wanting to settle
and enjoy being single.
Exactly. There we go. Yeah.
Haven't had a girlfriend before so you
don't know how to set up a relationship.
Yeah. Cause you're setting
this one up dude. Come on.
You got to have some self worth
here. Okay. Fuck this shit.
This isn't a muddy kids.
She's got a fuck buddy.
Bangs him one time after your first date.
Obviously she wasn't seeing fireworks.
The fuck is she doing with you?
All right.
Let her blow you one more time
and show her the fucking door.
Sorry.
Got Emotional.
I'll let the up all this respect
this and I'll read the rest. Uh,
though I was getting sick of the single
life when I got with her and we'd be
bummed out with the prospect of getting
laid less than once a month. Yeah.
You know something.
You're both using each other.
I, you're five months in. I really
hope you're not in love with this girl.
Said I have graduated and want to move
out of our city partly to move in with a
really good friend who I miss who lives
in interstate and she still has one year
to go and doesn't seem keen on moving.
Okay.
In your words based on that one incident.
I think I already told you.
I don't think she's going to be the mother
of my children areas and I'll always
think of it when I tell people how we met.
I feel like could be missing out on
advancing my career and being with my best
friend as I've grown apart
from my other friends,
as well as getting out of my shitty
small town to you think I should move out
and cut this thing.
Short apps a Fuckin lutely and you know
you should get out of your shitty small
town. Fuck this, this girl,
she's going to be in that same bar every
fucking Christmas when you come home to
visit your parents.
Okay,
she's going to be there and every year
of face is going to get a little fatter
and she might have more ink on her fucking
arm and you are going to be moving on
with your life.
All right?
And then one day you're not gonna
want to go back to that bar.
You just gonna drive by it and
you're going to be like, I want to,
if she's in there and you're not going
to give a fuck because the girl you give
your dreams is going to be in your seat
and you're gonna drive right by on this
perfectly fucking snow covered road.
There's a picture for you.
But that's only gonna happen if you dump
this whore and get out of that small,
Shitty town. All right.
That was a good one, Huh?
Um, okay. All, all of
garden chronicles, Eh,
Billy boy. I am a 24 year old part time
college student working at Olive Garden.
And this new chick here has been
a real flirt towards me. Uh,
I see just about all the signs. She
always tells me how delicious I smelled.
Gross, how bad she wants
to play with my hair. Okay.
One time when I was testing out a drink,
she took the glass,
rotate it to the part where my
mouth wasn't drank on it from there.
All right. So you know, she swallows.
Um, so what do you plan on
taking old ass to mouth?
Sorry. Uh, for some
reason I found that hot.
Ah, this guy's fucking hilarious.
Everything about her was, was, uh,
everything about her
was incredible figure,
nice tits and glasses made her look
even sexier with her pinned up hair.
One big problem. This is
a game changer. She 17.
Oh Gee, dude, she's got major
fucking daddy issues. Come on dude.
Okay.
There's plenty of horrors that are of age.
Uh,
do I really need to read the rest of this?
We got off at the same time the other
night and just started talking outside.
Oh Dude, if this fucking goes to
some sexual thing, if I read it as I,
my part of the fucking crime
is 17 legal in your state.
Some states it is just the good old boy.
Um,
I did the gentleman thing and asked her
if she needed a ride home. Fuck you.
You fucking cunt. Don't lie to me. Huh?
I thought we were friends calling me up.
You're asking for advice and then you
fall. You think I'm a fucking moron.
You didn't do the generally thing yet.
Deck was fucking pushing through
your zipper and you look good.
You want to ride home,
you want to fucking ruin this girl tried
to do the gentlemen there. You fuck.
You know what I see just for that.
I shouldn't even read the rest of this,
but I'm too fucking interested.
Um,
she politely declined and said her sister
wants to pick her up adding that she
doesn't want to use me like that.
She also said she was afraid that she
might get you used to it and expect it
every time we work together.
Understandable. It's not understandable.
She's fucking jerking you around.
She's putting on a God damn
fucking PG 13 sex show,
you know,
inside the bar. And then he'd
get outside, hey, there's my car.
You want to just fucking continue on
with the little show now. That's okay.
This might be one of these girls
that get Dick fucking, you know,
hard is a fucking rock. And
then just walks away. Just
wants to see you chase it.
And the only way you're going to get it
as if you just fucking walk away from it
and she'll follow you home like
a lost puppy. But she's 17,
so you don't want that to
happen. Um, anyways, however,
she asked me to stick around and keep
her company until her ride comes.
She asked me where I
usually hang out. Do, can I,
am I gonna get in trouble for this shit?
I'm not reading the rest of the,
she's only,
she's okay
tea. Once you call kip winger, he'll tell
you what the fuck to do. I say walk away.
All right.
The only question you should be
asking her is when are you turning 18.
And when she says, why say, because,
uh, I'll tell you on your birthday.
Alrighty. That's a podcast
for this week. Everybody, uh,
bittersweet this week. You
know, uh, Rondo went down,
tore his ACL. I fucking love
the Celtics. I really do.
And I know there's a lot of
people to hate the Boston Celtics,
but you know something, if I can
appreciate the fact that power was,
solves a great basketball
player and Colby Bryan,
now the got even as a Laker Fan, come on,
you got to, you got it. You have to admit,
unless you just a straight up con,
the fucking Celtics got more heart than
any other team in the league. You know,
they do.
You know they do.
Okay.
I'm telling you, they will fight you
to the end. Even fucking Colby said it.
He said the Celtics never fucking quit.
And if you guys think that can,
cause Rondo has gone down,
that this team is going to roll over.
Jurati your fucking mind.
All right.
The only way this team rolls over as if
Danny Ainge and those guys break it up.
That's the only way.
That's the only fucking way.
And I was flying to God knows fucking
wear and I missed that whole Celtics heat
game. But I have been watching the
Bruins. I watched him come back tonight,
um, after the hurricanes tied
it up. Hurricanes look good,
man. Great cold tend to in the country
is for checking I've ever seen.
Uh, but we somehow survived
it, but they're a great team.
We've got the devil's tomorrow night
when they were always great. So, uh,
I can't believe how much I
missed hockey when it came back.
I just absolutely fucking love it.
It's the greatest Goddamn sport and I
love that. Most people think it's sucks.
Please by all means continue
to not watch it. I love this.
It's great.
Okay.
Being the fourth most popular sport,
it's great. You know what that's like?
That's like being like a,
Oh, what's it like being,
it's like being the bass player in this
fucking awesome band and you're just
collecting checks, but when you walk
off stage, nobody recognizes you.
Nobody gives a fuck.
They're all running all over to the singer
and the lead guitarist and you get to
live a life.
Go down on the beach,
drink a fucking six pack
with your rock star money.
You know you got enough money to
get a good look and fucking woman.
She would have to deal with the,
what am I talking about?
I can't remember what the fuck,
what was he just talking about?
Being a hockey fan?
It's great.
I'm sorry guys. I'm fine. I was a,
I've been on four planes in three days.
All right. There's my excuse.
I'm limping home. All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
As always,
if you want to buy something on amazon.com
and donate to the Monday morning
podcast, just go to the podcast page on
[inaudible] dot com we have a banner ad.
You click right on the Amazon.
Uh,
banner takes you right to
Amazon and you're on there.
You don't have to do anything else.
Everything's still the same price.
They kicked me a percentage.
I take a percentage of that actually,
percentage of all my advertising,
10% to be exact,
and I give it to the
wounded warriors project.
You'll be supporting this podcast and a,
and the wounded warriors project and a,
that is it. That's the podcast
for this week. Go Fuck Yourself.
Enjoy the super bowl.
Uh,
give a shot if you haven't already
committed to a Superbowl party,
if we're already committed, still
taped the game at home. Okay.
And then just sit down and
watch it and look for that play.
I'm gonna look forward to
the pistol fucking formation.
Okay.
I can't even know what
the fuck it's called.
Okay.
Sheila,
when they said Shit,
it's basically a hot read the fuck
are you talking about John Gruden?
Which come out with a book and explain
it to me. What is the cover? Two defense.
All right, that's it. Go fuck
yourselves. We'll talk to you next week.
She's, she's a, and this is
not, it doesn't seem like
this is the girl for you.
She might be a little too advanced
alligator arm it. This might not be the
girl for you. She's a little too advanced.
This woman is a fucking war pig.
You're not. I'm trying to be
like tender and you know, Nice.
You know what alligator arm means?
You don't watch sports now I don't.
You know what?
I really don't appreciate when I come
down here and having this conversation
with you and you want to
throw these little sports
things that me and you always,
you always say, oh, you don't
watch sports. Oh, you didn't
get the sports they like,
you'd have to like remind me that I'm
not on the same level as you like,
so I'm not going to get all your amazing
sports references and terms and phrases
and I don't appreciate that. Can you
guys believe that went in 10 minutes
of just going on this rant about how dumb
I am and how innocent I am with using
the word fag and I,
I don't even have like an innocent hard,
but you're dumb and you're,
you just respond with rage the whole way.
You made me this fucking like simpleton.
Yeah. Be doing everything but fucking,
you know,
being in a big goof like,
hey, what are you doing?
Look walking down the street like you
don't want accidentally crushed somebody
to death trying to hug them. That's how
you just painted me. You're like, yeah,
you're like of a, of mice and men.
That's how you're painting me.
Within 10 minutes of this you're Lenny
and of mice and men. That's how you get,
that's exactly how you described me.
I was too dumb to know
that fucking reference
cause I, I see alligator arm is okay.
You've seen an alligator, right? Yeah.
Do they have long arms now?
They do not. They do not. And
it's basically, it's a, uh,
it's a sports term.
MMM.
Somebody throws you the ball and you
could actually reach out and get it,
but you don't totally reach out cause
you're worried about getting hit. Okay.
Sort of ally alligator arm it. It's
like Ah, so if you don't catch the ball,
the guy can't hit you.
Oh okay. I thought so.
I'm saying so your alligator arm
and this and that, you're going,
this girl isn't the girl for you
but blah blah blah. He's in, he's,
he's in there with the fucking pit viper,
right.
He's the goat and she's the on,
he is the STD free goat and
he is walking into a fucking
Bader of just,
I mean,
I mean this girl probably I want
to get it to still fucking for you.
She's not the girl for you.
That's bad advice.
Why this girl and telling you these
what the fucking HIG and you'd have to
suppose to do about it.
Tell the whole fucking school,
I'm just saying she's not the girl for
you. Move on to somebody else's more.
Your speed. Why is that bad advice?
Because you're acting like, you know,
she's not into sports,
likes to eat and is a morning person.
He likes sports and staying up. You know
what? This person is like, you know,
this person isn't for you. I meant as
like a foodie. It's like, it's a simple
way of saying that, you know you should
move on. That's, that's all it is. No,
it's like you're sitting there with a
toddler and he's about ready to touch a
hot stove. You gotta be like, they has
to be a sense of urgency here. Like,
like, no, no, no, no, no. This, this
will hurt you. It was, well, you know,
you make that little fucking can. They
don't even speak English. You're trying to
fucking, when they can't, they can't
speak yet. You're trying to fuck him.
I go fuck yourself.
You're, you're sitting there talking
to this person like, um, hey,
try some of this sandwich. Yeah,
I didn't really like that bread.
Well maybe you'll like this bread like it.
Like it's just like this whimsical,
there's too many Daisy's. And
what you're saying, this is,
this is a very dangerous situation.
This guy should stay away from this girl
on all fucking in all girls like this.
She's got a, she's on her period and
she has no fucking like, like class.
She has opened so leg,
like what was he supposed to do?
Pull it out and just go off on it.
There's other ways she suggesting anal.
This girl, it's like if she's a
fucking mess, stay away from this girl.
This girl get pregnant.
This girl will give you a fucking disease.
This girl was steal your laptop
screen is a fucking nightmare.
Knock it off. All right. All
right. Advice for a lady.
Dear Bill, I've been with my
boyfriend for two years now.
We're in college together
and he's currently taking a
semester abroad. Oh Jesus.
Where in Brazil.
Before he left,
we had a running joke that I was going
to need a vibrator when he left as a
surprise party gift.
He got me one.
I have a couple of friends whose
boyfriends bought them sex toys,
so while I was a little surprised
he actually got me a vibrator.
I also happen to know that
it's a relatively normal,
it's relatively normal for a
boyfriend and do that. Yeah.
That's basically like this
era's chastity belt. You know,
you're trying to lock down the pussy.
That's disgusting Ed. Yeah, that,
but that's what he's doing now anyway.
Yeah. But it's done because those things,
you use them too much.
They numb up your area there and then
the guy can't even remotely try and,
you know,
okay,
do something for it. And then you gotta
be sitting there, Bang, Bang. And I'm,
as their user are using the thing as,
you know,
it's like you want an
alien or fucking this girl.
That's just all dick has no body.
All right, whatever. Let's move on.
One of the basing it on and
pay some of my fucking life.
I did live a little bit of a life before
I met you. I realize that. All right.
Any way, fast forward to about a
week ago, we were on Skype. Uh,
he asked you to take this thing out. Um,
no, we don't have sex chats. Thank God.
And he casually asked me how his
gifts for me was working out.
I told them it was
working out pretty well.
He then mentioned that he had
bought something for himself.
A fleshlight
Joe experience is brought to you
by the fleshlight every week.
He does a very, very weird,
those are very lucky in okay.
They look like that thing.
Boba Fett I fell into when he died
in one of those space movies. Okay.
Wow. Um, I knew how to be faithful
to right. That's nice. Okay.
He said,
she goes,
I knew what this was because I am an
avid listener of Joe Rogan's podcast.
You go,
Joe Robbins come up three times on this
podcast who raves about it constantly.
My boyfriend had never had mentioned to
me that he was interested in anything
like that, and I always thought
the idea of it was totally creepy.
I acted like it was totally cool,
but in all honesty,
I really don't want him to beat
fucking a perfect fake wait.
I got lost in that.
I actually was thinking as Joe going
to get mad that I'm saying that this is
weird. Okay. I acted like it was
totally cool, but in all honesty,
I really don't want them to be fucking
of perfect fake vagina whenever he wants
to.
I'm finding myself getting crazy jealous
and angry whenever I think about it.
I know, I know I'm jealous of an
inanimate object, which seems insane.
Let me finish.
I'm really struggling with this because
part of me wants to be completely okay
with it since it's sort of a hypocrite.
It's sort of hypocritical to get
angry when he got me a vibrator.
But now I'm starting to think that maybe
he only bought me a Dildo so I wouldn't
be able to complete when he
got himself a proxy pussy. Ah,
Roxy Pussy.
So what do you think?
Do I need to suck it up and get over
this or is my jealousy legitimate?
Thanks and go fuck yourself
Polaris and go fuck is fake pussy.
As long as he's not faking a real pussy,
I mean fucking a real pussy and
then you know it's all good.
Plus you, you, it's not just
like the, the pussy that it's,
that he's missing. He's
also missing like, you know,
your touch and kissing and the
whole other part of it too.
And that fake pussy cat. Oh,
am I there? No, he isn't.
He's getting right to the dessert.
Don't be Jackie.
Try these Brussels sprouts. Don't
need them. Don't be jealous.
I bring over the trace late Lecce when
he comes back it will be even better
because you both have been like doing
it with inanimate objects. And so it's,
I don't think the rediscovering each
other all over again. I'll be even better.
I don't think. We don't even worry.
I don't think it's a good thing.
Why? Because, uh,
once you start down a path sexually,
you know,
in order to get off that path, you
don't just jump over onto another path.
You got to walk all the way
back up the path you went down,
get to the fork where you fucked up
and then head down the other one.
What I'm saying is he might get used to
just doing that and this sensation of
that is what gets him off. And then when
her pussy doesn't feel like fleshlight,
he'll, you don't feel better. He'll,
he'll build bang her and then,
and then when he needs to
finish, he'll be like, all right,
and now for me and what
that fucking thing.
Oh, even better if anything
he'll be like, oh my God,
I forgot what a real woman feels like.
And he'll be done in like two minutes.
That's what your hope. Um, I
don't think she should be jealous.
I'm at though.
They're both,
they're both doing the right thing when
you're in a relationship and you're that
far apart from each other because I bang
all sorts of Harry European girls and
no offense to hear European girls,
but I'm just saying, you know, listen,
I watched this thing one time or
listen to it on the radio, uh,
one of those Colin's sex shows
and this guy had a pull away.
He jerked off to see dry hump.
The rug it was causing,
like chafing on is decorative, but it, it,
it was the only way he could get off
because he wasn't in a relationship for a
while and he kept doing that and I dunno.
So I'm just saying like,
I would go easy on those. It's like
anything, anything in moderation.
How often is he using this and
how often is she using that?
If you's a vibrate too much,
you numb yourself up down there.
And then when you guys down there
I that he can't feel anything.
It's so disgusting. Um, overrated.
Underrated for the week. Overrated.
The Superbowl, underrated rounds one
and two of the NFL playoffs. Bill,
this may be sacrilegious
to say in America,
but I actually enjoy rounds one and two
of the NFL playoffs more than the super
bowl.
That is a sector religious because at no
point is beyond say or Brittany Spears
sing before and in the
halftime show there's not a
bunch of douchebags who don't
like football showing up feeling
like they have to be there.
You know all the broad why you yeah,
why are you looking at me?
Cause you go to super bowl parties
every year and you hate football. Yeah.
Well they're fun. They're nice gatherings.
Talk when the game's on. No I don't.
They run yap.
When the most important game is on,
it's disgusting. If you do it again
this year we're breaking up each week.
You get two games both
on Saturday and Sunday.
There seems to be that
we can win this thing,
excitement in the air and I can relax
and watch the games and the comfort of my
home or at a local bar without dozens
of non-fans in the room as is typically
the case of the Superbowl party Superbowl
and the other hand has become so
pretentious in recent years.
I don't even really want to get
worked up for it as much as I used to.
The game takes forever.
85% of the commercial sucks and we're
forced to stare at Madonna's beat up face
for 30 minutes during a halftime show
plus the two week gap in between the
Superbowl and the conference champion
really takes the air out of the sales.
What are your thoughts?
I think this is what you do.
You watch the Superbowl alone and you
tape it and you start watching it.
You DVR it and you watch,
you let you let you give the
game a 90 minute headstart
and then then you just sit down,
you watch it by yourself and you plow
through the pregame and you just watched
the fucking game.
And when the halftime show comes,
you fast forward through that and now
you're under the third quarter and third
quarter and fourth quarter it's
going to be regular time football.
That's the way to watch the Superbowl.
And you watch it by yourself.
Maybe with another buddy of yours
who that uh, enjoys the game.
That's how I would do it,
you know?
No thoughts on that. No. But
what about the social aspects?
Shut up.
You were going to have brownies
during the old cheese doodles.
Oh my God. The way the broad talk
to her and that fucking game.
And then now and then,
and it's true women who like,
and everybody shuts up to
watch the commercials and then,
and then the game comes back
on the, I took that one was
late. What did you think?
Well, that's definitely the best one
so far. How much did that cost? Well,
why don't you start going of a
Superbowl parties then, Bill,
why don't you stop if
you don't like the game,
I don't do any of that stuff that
you're talking about. I don't,
I don't like needle point. I don't go to
your fucking metapoint parties to late.
They don't do any order.
You do arts and crafts.
I don't crash the super bowl or those
things and come there and talk when you're
trying to glue the popsicle sticks
together and then shut the fuck up.
When a talk throughout the game,
I go in the other room or I hang out
with other people if they're lies. Lies,
lies. Yeah. No lies. Lies. Lies. Okay.
That's the Monday morning podcast. Oh,
before I get out of here. Huh? That's it.
That's it. We did a nice long one. All
right. There's nothing else. No. Okay.
Um, amazon.com everybody,
if you want to, um,
if you want to buy something on
amazon.com and support my podcast,
go to [inaudible] dot com
click on the podcast page.
Take it. We've got a link. Uh,
what did it be? It, the little
box, a little window thing,
the little a little icon.
You Click on that thing. I have no
idea what they're called. Banner ad.
You Click on it, you're going
to amazon.com you buy something.
They kicked me back a little bit of money.
I take 10% of that and I throw it to
the wounded warriors project. You,
you sponsored this and the wounded
warriors. See that's it. Everybody.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves. And uh, yeah.
Do you ever get with it
girl? And she spreads her leg with the,
the rip cord there. All right. You're the,
she's the snake. Get the fuck
out of the cage. See you.